la afición blaugrana no podrá despedir
con una ovación en el estadio al jugador
que más ha hecho vibrar al camp nou en
rueda de prensa entre lágrimas leo messi
dijo adiós al club que lo ha visto
crecer tristeza mucha tristeza porque me
tengo que ir de tecla el club al que amo
y en un momento que no lo esperaba
porque como dije al principio y nunca
mentir y siempre fui de frente diciendo
la verdad
el año pasado quería irme este no el
famoso comunicado que messi mandó hace
un año al barça para expresar su
voluntad de irse dejó a los culés con el
corazón en un puño y llevó a incluir la
palabra burofax por primera vez entre
las líneas del 'new york times' en
detalles así se mide el brillo del astro
que logró seis balones de oro y que ha
sido responsable por gol o asistencia de
uno de cada once tantos marcados en la
historia del barcelona en los 17 años
que messi ha jugado en el equipo como
profesional el barça ha ganado casi el
40% de los títulos de sus 122 años de
existencia el número 10 quedará inscrito
en el legado del club como el mejor
jugador de su historia pero con una
tesorería crítica la junta directiva del
club decidió no endeudarse más y no
renovar a su estrella frente a
dificultades económicas incluso para
inscribirlo en la liga al margen de cuál
fuera la reducción de su millonario
sueldo
un eventual nuevo acuerdo yo había
bajado mi ficha habíamos ahorrado el
contrato y después no se me pidió
mandado sin destino confirmado y con la
promesa de volver algún día a la que
considera su ciudad barcelona el
argentino que llegó a la masía con 13
años pone fin a la historia que empezó
con un contrato firmado en una
servilleta y que lo llevó de su natal
rosario a la gloria